the build-up is nearly over a year later
than planned
the biggest sporting event since the
pandemic brought life to a standstill
is set to begin with england scotland
and wells in contention the hope is that
the european football championships will
help lift the spirits of the nations
i'm getting a bit of that 1996 vibe
starting to go on now you know that with
that
real sense of of excitement and and
involvement
and national interest and of course the
pandemic is
is adding to that
in many ways that feel good factor will
look and sound very different
before the passion agony and ecstasy
that come with watching the beautiful
game
will come precautions social distancing
measures are in place at the 11 stadiums
hosting the tournament
while capacity at many of the grounds
including in london and glasgow is
limited
a ticket will no longer be enough for
fans coming to watch the games here at
wembley
in a sign of the times they will need to
show proof of full vaccination
or a negative covid test to enter the
stadium
for people watching the game away from
stands in pubs bars and restaurants
the fun will also be more organized than
usual
this pub in surrey is expecting the
euros to boost profits
but they face a balancing act between
serving pints and enforcing restrictions
we are certainly expecting a bit of a
bump especially on the england games
where
most of our pubs are sold out already
fully booked
um so which is great as far as i'm
concerned because it means
we can monitor the numbers and and all
that and and
not have hundreds of people turn up or
just expecting a table
covet isn't the only concern ahead of
the event the controversy around fans
brewing england flair's decision to take
the knee will continue to be a talking
point
i cannot understand the mentality of any
fan who pays for a ticket
travels to a stadium to support the team
and then the first thing they do as the
referee bros the whistle is to boo their
own players it's beyond comprehension
the tournament kicks off tonight in rome
before wales led by gareth bale become
the first of the british sides to play
tomorrow
taking on switzerland in baku
england preparing as usual at st
george's park hosts croatia at wembley
on sunday
and scotland will hope to make the most
of their home advantage when they face
the czech republic at hamden park on
monday
for fans who have had to wait an extra
12 months for this feast of european
football
the hope is that 2021 will be the odd
year the trophy comes home
shinki mararike sky news